you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the uk government will set in law the
world's most ambitious climate change
target we hear what it'll mean for you
as well as big business
the young people campaigning to save the
planet and expecting world leaders
to take notice and environmental
activist erin brockovich tells sky news
the world
isn't acting quickly enough on climate
change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis explain the
data driving the changes that are
already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come now today the uk government's
announced what it's calling a world
leading target to cut carbon emissions
by
78 by 2035 from 1990 levels
it's one of the most ambitious
environmental targets set out by a
developed nation
and takes the uk more than three
quarters of the way to reaching net zero
emissions
by 2050. so here's what it could mean
for you
everyone will need to eat less meat and
dairy whether that's cutting down the
amount that you have or committing fully
to a plant-based diet homes will need to
be much better insulated and people will
be encouraged to switch from gas
to low carbon heating the government's
banning the sale of new petrol and
diesel cars so there'll be more electric
cars on the road
and we'll all need to change the way we
travel by driving less and walking and
cycling
more air travel is expected to become
more expensive for frequent
flyers and short haul flights could be
banned where train or bus alternatives
exist
and couples may be encouraged to have
fewer children as a way of reducing
their carbon footprint one of the key
things the government will need to do
is match policies and practice with the
rhetoric of cutting emissions but
an initiative which was designed to help
people with things like insulation the
green homes grant was scrapped just six
months
after it was launched well our climate
correspondent lisa holland is a
at a company in birmingham which was
part of that scheme
so lisa how hard is it going to be for
the government to reach its target by
2035
it's a really ambitious target and it
should be good
theoretically for businesses like this
in birmingham which installs
insulation we know that about 20 percent
of our emissions in the uk
come from our buildings so we need to
better insulate them and stop
energy from escaping there was this
scheme the green homes grant
which was launched by the government
this business here said that it was
fairly chaotic
scheme and that's the knob of the
problem the policies the foundation
for getting to net zero uh has to match
that ambition
and the jury frankly is still out about
whether that will happen
lisa thank you well one of the key
things announced today is that for the
first time the uk's carbon budget will
incorporate the country's share
of international aviation and shipping
emissions well with me is our business
correspondent helen ann smith so hello
anne why is that important
well it matters massively because
aviation alone accounts for a huge
proportion of our
greenhouse gas emissions but big
business will be seeing this i think
today is a bit of a
challenge and an opportunity an
opportunity because they get to
potentially access new markets develop
new technology but a huge challenge as
well because particularly for those
bigger emitters some of them will need
to
radically pivot their businesses and
pivot them very fast and all businesses
will need to make
cuts back in 2018 for example businesses
alone
accounted for about 18 of our greenhouse
gas emissions so a big amount
and look while there are lots and lots
of strategies and blueprints and plans
on the table for how different sectors
are going to
cut their emissions what a lot of people
are saying is that when it comes to
business there needs to be a stick as
well as a carrot
the best example of this is probably the
automotive industry that new law that
we're now aware of
whereby you can't sell petrol diesel
cars from 2030. it was only once that
legislative thing came in that we saw a
huge swathe of
car companies moving to electrifly their
fleet so that really matters
hello nan thank you now those
commitments from the uk government come
as a new report from the international
energy agency has found
global carbon dioxide emissions from
energy production
are on course to surge by one and a half
billion tons
this year now that would be the second
largest increase in history
and here on our data dashboard you can
see how total co2 emissions
are ticking up all the time and they of
course have a big influence
on this number here human-induced global
warming
so here's those iea findings in a little
bit more detail
and you can see the change in co2
emissions
by fuel from 1990 up to
this year now the light blue color is
coal then
oil is in dark blue and finally gas is
in yellow and the drop that you can see
here is due to global lockdowns last
year because of the covert 19
pandemic but demand for all fossil fuels
is set to grow significantly in 2021
with global energy demand set to
increase by nearly
five percent this year however the iea
did find that renewables remain the
success story
of the covet 19 era and they're set to
provide more than half of the increase
in global electricity supply
in 2021 and on our data dashboard you
can see
the real-time power mix in great britain
now today
fossil fuels as you can see account for
54 of our energy
renewables 29 and nuclear
17 and according to the chief executive
of national grid
progress in renewable energy will be
crucial to helping the government meet
its net zero target
most people think only about 10 percent
by electricity comes from renewables
but actually in 2020 55
of all the electricity that we had in
the uk came from zero carbon generation
so if you compare that with just five
years ago for example so five years ago
about 25 percent of our electricity in
the uk came from coal
last year it was just 1.6 meanwhile the
national grid has developed a smart
low energy led light bulb that glows
green to signal when your electricity in
your home
is powered by clean or green energy
sources
it's part of a campaign to help people
make smarter decisions about their
energy consumption
they hope that people will choose to do
things like their laundry or
charging an electric car when they know
their energy is coming from renewable
sources
and you can see a more detailed
breakdown of the real-time energy mix on
our website
just head to skynews.com climate
in today's other climate news natural
habitats will play a crucial role in
getting the uk
to net zero emissions by 2050. that's
according to a report by
natural england which suggests certain
ecosystems can take huge amounts of
carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere researchers have
found a hectare of ancient woodland is
capable of storing the same amount of
co2
each year that would be emitted from 13
plane journeys
between london and rome
[Applause]
scientists are using neon coloured orbs
to investigate the
impact rockfalls have on the environment
test rocks the heaviest weighing 3200
kilograms
would drop down shroud bactobal mountain
in the east of switzerland
warmer temperatures thought permafloor
frost that's found on mountaintops
and it causes rocks that were previously
held in place by the ice
to loosen and fall downhill
and thailand is close to completing one
of the world's biggest
floating solar farms more than 144
000 solar panels have already been
installed on the surface
of the syrinthorn dam in one of the
country's northeastern provinces
authorities say it'll have the capacity
to generate 2725 megawatts of power
when it's complete
now on thursday president biden will
host the earth day summit
bringing together leaders from 40
countries around the world
and today a digital youth-led summit is
taking place to discuss
climate issues and form demands that
will be presented to the international
meeting
later this week ashna harinag has been
speaking to activists from australia
uganda and the u.s about their
experience of climate campaigning
[Applause]
a generation fighting for their futures
determined to not let their lives be
crippled by climate change
greta thundberg may be credited with a
school strike snowball effect but across
the world the climate voices
are getting louder and younger
sixteen-year-old anjali sharma
is taking the australian government to
court over a new coal mine
she says the burden of responsibility
weighs heavy on young shoulders
i think that while it is really
empowering you know like i
come home sometimes at the end of a long
day of um you know a school strike
meeting
or um you know the end of the press
conference and i feel really
accomplished but then it's also kind of
bittersweet because it's like
it sucks that i have to take my future
into my own hands from the front line of
the climate crisis
in uganda activist vanessa says many are
disconnected from a crisis
they can't see we are all
facing the same storm but we are
definitely
in different boats so meaning there are
communities that are
being affected right now the communities
whose bots are sinking faster or
burning faster but in the end of it all
if nothing is done about this then
everybody is going to catch fire
then every boat is going to drown
at 20 kevin is demanding cleaner air for
americans
he says his peers are vocal about
demanding change
because they care young people are
really making the connections between
women's rights
uh civil rights and environmentalism and
climate change
that's the reason why young people are
so heavily involved is because we want
to grow up in a world
where we don't have to be plagued by
these injustices these disparities
and inequalities as leaders of the
future their passion is driving the
climate movement
a generation of trailblazers determined
not to be drowned out
ashley harinad sky news
yesterday we told the story of what
residents call michigan's most toxic
postcode where locals have spent years
fighting the quality of the air that
they are breathing in
and you can see cordelia lynch's report
on the 48217 district on our youtube
channel or watch yesterday's episode on
catch up
now as part of that report cordelia
spoke to renowned environmental activist
erin brockovich whose successful lawsuit
against the pacific gas and electric
company
was turned into a hollywood hit starring
julia roberts
i know covet is our priority and right
behind it
should be the destruction
of this planet our water our air
and knowing that changes are coming and
we still won't get prepared
the conversation has to be had it has to
be
loud and it has to be all of us
how shocked and disappointed are you at
the kind of
status of america when it comes to
tackling climate change
on the global stage yeah i'm really
frustrated and you know i always
i really try to
listen understand respect
here both sides certainly the people
i've been doing this i started at 31
i'm 60. nothing's changed
do you think that america is confronting
environmental racism enough
no and i don't think we have been and
i've been out here for 20 years and
they're
at a disadvantage and they get taken
advantage of it's wrong at every ever
i'm see i'm not going to drop an f-bomb
and i almost did it's wrong
at every level and it sickens me
and i don't understand whoever those
powers to be why
it is you can't hear
the people who were down on the ground
drinking the water
eating the food living in these
conditions
frightened suffering and nothing
has gotten done we think what's
happening in mission may just be
happening in michigan
but it also happened in hinkley but i'm
here to tell you it's happening in maine
and it's happening in oklahoma
how comforting to you that america is
going to be able to catch up
quickly enough because it seems to be a
long way behind on this
for as daunting as everything sees i see
a watershed moment well that's
everything from us for today
on the daily climate show tomorrow how
planting seagrass off the coast of
plymouth
could help absorb millions of tons of
carbon and tackle climate change
that's at the same time here on sky news
see you then